my interest in cloud computing relate to
kind of this data analysis data analysis
data discovery problem of being able to
scan through very large volumes of DNA
sequences a lot of the technologies that
were developed for cloud computing were
actually entirely invented in other
disciplines so in particular large-scale
internet companies like Google and
Facebook and Twitter have developed
these technologies out of necessity so
one of the key technologies that I that
I thought that I utilized that I looked
to as a technology called MapReduce that
was invented at Google and for a long
time this was their secret sauce if you
will for being able to do these very
large studies of of many trillions of
webpages scanning through trillions of
web pages is not so different than
scanning through trillions of DNA
sequences a lot of a lot of the
approaches that you would use for that
those studies are exactly the same so
I've borrowed heavily from kind of that
sort of community the text mining
database community and then any sort of
discipline where there's there tends to
be a large volumes of data these
technologies are rapidly gaining
traction just because they are so
powerful the first main technical
challenge is if we have many thousands
of genomes who want to study how could
we load all that information into the
cloud right the-the-the the way you
would want to do that is you know
through your web browser or through your
computer but the the internet capacity
is only is only so big and if you have
to chip you know this conceptual pile of
to of two miles of DVDs shipping that
around on the internet takes four dicks
takes too long there are some ways to
overcome this it's a little bit funny to
think about it but but in some ways the
most practical way to ship very large
data sets is to use FedEx or UPS or some
sort of physical shipment of hard drives
through the mail it's not a you know
it's not the sexy application that you
would want for an Internet company but
that's a that's a practical way to do it
so that's the main technical barrier and
then storing data in the cloud opens up
a lot of other challenges and
particulars a lot of privacy concerns
about making sure that that data
is is really well-guarded your your
genome is your has a lot of information
about who you are what sort of diseases
you're susceptible to could say a lot
about your family about your children by
your ancestors you know it's it's
precious information that we that we
definitely don't want to expose without
without giving it some consideration so
the concern is is if if all of this
genetic information is in the cloud and
you're not careful about how that data
is protected it could leak out it could
you know you know could accidentally be
exposed to other people and then also if
big archives are made that has collected
many thousands of people this could
suddenly become an attractive target so
today we're a little bit guarded in the
sense of this genetic information is
decentralized in many different labs so
that if there's a breach at one lab it's
relatively localized if everything gets
aggregated together it becomes a little
bit more risky because it becomes a
little bit more attractive as a target
I think these challenges can be overcome
the encryption technologies the
authentication technologies they exist
they certainly exists and there are
companies that that run with the highest
level of security at Amazon Cloud and
other cloud resources it is it is
certainly possible to do so but we just
got to be so certain that we get it
right on the first try alright we don't
want to create this big database that
has all the student and Ike information
and then accidentally leave it
vulnerable we just have to be really
careful about how that's engineering
you